hey guys welcome back to ichi live it's
another very special Celebrity Big
Brother breakdown I am Bryce sander I'm
Katie Krause being here know I still
don't like seeing you outside of the Big
Brother house I mean I do and I don't
you know I didn't want to leave I mean
but it's nicer out here people are much
nicer than me on the outside
now that you've sort of had time to
process what actually went down more a
few days from you leaving the house how
are you feeling I'm feeling good I mean
I'm still sad because I wanted to play
the challenges if I could just go in and
do the challenges that'd be so fun
well we were talking about otev we think
that maybe otev will be this week and I
feel like as a Big Brother fan we would
love to play otev or is that what you're
most bummed about like the different she
wants a job I wanted the home
yes I wanted the wall so I was really
bummed because we figured it out yeah
before I was a victims like you guys I
wanted to do the wall bed no sympathy
for me but otev and zingbot were two
things I really wanted to experience and
I don't think they're doing it I think I
was told they're not doing either one so
then that made me feel better yeah it's
not no one yes
all right we are gonna dive into
everything that's gone down in the last
week what's still to come there will be
some spoilers so if you don't follow
live feeds or don't want to get spoiled
from the episode that airs tonight maybe
click out of this save for later watch
after tonight's episode and should we
jump right in to kind of the biggest
bombshells of the last yeah so you were
evicted they just rolled that footage
back when did you know you were going
home um I mean I think the minute they
put me on like before they put me on the
block cuz I had figured it out before
they nominated like halfway through the
day I yeah we put it together cuz at
first I was told it was gonna be James
and Omarosa and then I realized nobody
was talking to me nobody's looking me in
the eye and James kind of came to me and
said wait how much do you trust Ross
like I feel like he might be flipping on
us and he put
together first and I was like let's test
this out and I was like yeah you're
right that's what's happening how
disappointed are you in Ross and Marissa
because they really did seem like your
friends and your allies and you guys
seem like a very strong group yeah are
you still hurt I know that you said
you're not gonna vote for them in the
end if they make it yep no change there
no it's funny because you know Ross was
saying when he was in there before I
left he's like just go watch the
episodes you'll see there are reasons I
did everything and I'm I've watched some
of them like wow it's worse than I
thought
like everything they did is way worse
than I even imagined because I didn't
know they were plotting the week before
and that was the week I helped him get
his HOH yeah like he wouldn't have been
HOH if I hadn't talked to James and said
throw it James would have been well what
hurt the most
like what diary room or what
conversation the hardest conversation
was the conversation I had with Omarosa
after he flipped the house and you guys
only saw part of that it actually got
much worse
it was much below the belt and outside
of the game some of the things that she
said to me so that was a hard
conversation but I I think it just it
hurt knowing they turned on me so early
like you expect it later right I was
protecting him I was doing everything to
help them stay in the house we won
everything I did was for the group and
they didn't give me any credit for it
and then everything I said they found
ways to turn it around and like play it
against me so it's like I really felt
like I couldn't do anything right right
yeah it's like something happened where
everybody got it in their head that you
were the enemy when really you were the
one pushing the game forward and it's
just because you were such a threat like
you came out as such a strong player so
in a way it was smart of them but for us
it was such a bummer and for you was
such a bummer going into the house and
having watched all the seasons was it
completely different playing the game
than you thought it was gonna be I mean
it's different because it's shorter yeah
and that's why I made some of the
decisions I made because he didn't it
didn't feel like there was gonna be time
to sit back and fade into the background
and like not do anything like in a
normal season you kind of want to do
that but I'm like this is like three and
a half weeks or something you can't you
can't really do that so I made the
decision if I can win the first HOH win
it and use that power to build alliances
which sort of kind of worked but we kind
of had the girls thing before we even
went into that and then it was all taken
away from me when Keyshia took over
anyway yet I still got blamed for
everything that happened that was I
think what was the worst thing to happen
to you was her getting that twist yes
that sort of ruined everything well and
and if Chuck hadn't gone for the bag
yeah I think we we would have kept
nominations meta and Marc we would have
just tried to backdoor James which was
the plan to start with mm-hmm it was
Keyshia like I didn't even remember
until I saw the episodes I'm like it was
Keisha who originally suggested if he
goes for the bag we flip it and we put
in James and Chuck yeah yeah but I got
blamed for that right even in her eyes
she said I think she forgot that it was
her idea to yeah I just got blamed for
everything so after a while I was like
well the targets so big on me what do I
care let's just make it bigger like I
just was going for everything like how
where do you stand with James right now
yeah yeah I'm rooting for James now okay
you know you know why cuz I feel like he
has integrity like yes he couldn't stand
by me in the end but I don't blame him
because he needed to stick with the
numbers mm-hmm
but he's not in there bad-mouthing
people look that I've seen I mean maybe
is it I haven't seen it and maybe people
can let me know but he's not in there
just calling people names and I'm
watching some of the live feeds and
they're still in there calling me names
like and it's hurtful I don't know what
I did to make them so matter they say no
we love you to my face and then they're
they're calling me crazy and insane
behind my back I'm like I don't know
what I did that was so crazy and insane
I tried to save you guys and by the way
I did save you yeah do you think when
they watch the show back they're gonna
feel differently about what they did do
you think you're gonna get some
apologies no I don't think they will
I don't think they'll see it because I
think some so much of it happened over
the live feeds too and they're not going
to be able to go back and and see all
the live feeds so they're only gonna see
the edited show most likely and maybe
they even choose to watch it right
they probably well I would I don't know
I think everybody will watch it and they
might watch some of the highlights but
they'll probably be more affected by
what the public says to him whether the
public loves them or hates them whatever
is said to him over social media it's
probably what will affect the most yeah
let's move on to our next motion so
after your eviction we then lost meta
which was disappointing because both you
and Keisha told me in our exit
interviews that's who you wanted to win
that's who had your vote he did not have
a good answer in our exit interview as
to why he couldn't last one more week
yeah what do you think happened oh he he
so badly just wanted to like go home and
be with his wife and even when we had
the Valentine's Day messages are like
see Mara she said stick it out and win
that should be incentive enough and I
said this to him during like a
commercial break I'm like you can't jump
out of this house he tried to escape
three times that's crazy to me
oh yeah to everyone so I mean and the
fact that they they send him home this
week it was only to save all of
themselves right you know it wasn't
because they're like oh we're gonna do
your favor and send you home no it was
still very selfish because they wanted
to just save themselves because of that
twist the veto twist which was such a
bad week for if they'd done it my week
we might have been able to do something
interesting with it but but by Ross
winning it and they already had this all
planned out it was just kind of the way
a waste of a twist now is that
accommodation which we had never really
seen this veto competition before so
I'll be interested to see if this comes
back in regular Big Brother though what
I did love about this whole eviction
situation was Brandis speech - we
actually have the clip here Brandi
you're up I just want to say thank you
meta for wanting to go home
thank you brandy that was all she had to
say yeah it looked like you and Metta
the night before you were evicted had
some really good conversation that
looked like you guys were really bonding
where does that friendship stand right
now and was there anything that you
could have done um you know I did try
everything he even tried he tried to
talk to them and he's like they they
don't want to let me leave because they
don't want to play with you what do you
make of Brandi voting to keep you
nothing
not nothing thinks it was a ploy to get
her vote at the finale no I don't think
that that's what baby that's a day to
get her though I don't think she's that
clever okay so that means right away she
was thinking that far ahead I think she
literally just felt bad and wanted me to
not feel bad and thought well you know
if I give her a vote she won't feel so
bad yeah I really do think in the moment
she just said okay I'm just gonna give
her a vote yeah so I I don't think she
knows to think about jury votes like she
doesn't know the game she and Ari both
self-admittedly don't know the game
right so that's giving too much credit
okay I know the game no no no no there's
a handful of people that don't know the
game was just started like watching
metod even watch it ahead of time he's
like I don't want to know I just go play
like Bennett told me he would play the
game again
now knowing what it is but wanted out at
this point it was very confusing if you
want to actually never let him play the
game again yeah trust me the things that
he was saying I wish I could repeat them
for you maybe off-camera
like we would be going live in like a
minute and every curse word you could
think of aimed at like production
because he was still in the house was
coming out of his mouth and I could you
know production be like all right get it
out meta I always loved on life he was
like we do not talk about production Oh
but now I can't
we have some fan comments and questions
coming in and if you do have anything
that you want Shannon to know drop them
in the comments below
Madelene says hi what what do you think
you would do differently I wanted you to
win uh it would depend if it's a full
season or not and it would be hard now
because now people know how I play yeah
I I think what I would need is the
producers to be like alright you're
gonna go in and this is my my dream
you're gonna go in this regular season
as like a strategist that's gonna help
all the players so they come to you and
talk to you and bond with you and then
ideally all of the challenges I do it
first and set the time that they have to
beat and then so they do their normal
challenges but if they beat my time then
there's like an extra perk or something
oh it's the best of both worlds and then
maybe halfway through I could actually
say like the coaches season get in there
and talk to people and strategize and
have fun and bond and and then I can
play later
right Allison Grodner yes any former BB
players that you would love to play with
like to have on that season oh gosh I
mean it depends if I'm against them or
with them like I hit them with them like
I love Jenelle obviously yeah I love I
always love evil dick yeah and Angie's
laying and doctor well controversial
yeah great yeah great but like if we
were all on a team together we'd kill it
it would love that what do you have that
shield down to point out yes
kendra says you played an amazing game
debbie says she would love to see you
again
I mean a lot of people are on where you
are at where they want James to win at
this point yeah you know I just think
he's he's not he doesn't seem to be
backstabbing people he doesn't seem to
be playing in a hurtful way yes he was
strong and maybe because of that
everybody was wanting the underdogs in
the beginning but now I he kind of has
become the underdog because everyone's
against him in a way and they all keep
trying to backdoor him and they haven't
been able to do it so now I'm kind
like rooting for him to pull it he's
also playing the game in a very forward
way he just wants to win the comps and
yeah in that way yeah or throw it when
you make a deal when needed he's very
smart playing all around the cops versus
a lot of people are weighing a lot in
the social game right now yeah and I
mean he's got mark as his ride-or-die
which is fine and I mean it was smart of
him to do what he did this week which
you know you haven't spoiled it yet but
I'll do a spoiler alert now we're going
to dive into spoiler alerts this is our
youth is yes mine is the window come
back to it later come back in five
minutes our third bombshell of the week
is James through the comp for mark to
win HOH yes and he's nominated brandy
and re yes what do you make of those
nominations well I'm wondering if he
didn't know Murray nominate Omarosa
because he made a deal with her last
week okay and I'm thinking he might be
sticking to that deal even though he
wasn't exactly sticking it a deal with
the Ross stuff but it never came to it
cuz Ross pulled himself off so the deal
could still stand or he might just be
like oh we can backdoor but they're
smart which I don't know if they are but
if they're smart they get rid of Ari
this week because nobody wants to sit
next to Aria in the final two you can
sit next to Brandi you can make a case
next to brandy but Ari has just been
this little like butterfly in the
background that just looks like she's
beautiful and she's strong and she's
smart and nobody really has reason to to
not vote for her in the end right now
you gotta start getting rid of these
people she's kind of flowed a little bit
but she's won enough that it's proving
she's playing the game so it's this she
is kind of that sweet spot that we've
seen people win like Jordan and people
in the past I wouldn't want to sit next
to her in the end
so that's who I would get out this week
do you think she's smarter than people
in the house or giving her credit for I
feel like she's sliding by because
they're not they don't think that she's
math she plays a very good social game
because she's a very very sweet girl she
is inherently very sweet and quiet so
everyone loves her because of that yeah
and they they truly don't want to vote
her off because they are there they're
just playing like how Omarosa calls it
Club Med
they're just playing like a fun little
friendship game right now
so we'll see this week if they're
playing the game a big brother or
friendship right there's so much to go
down in the next four or five days yeah
it's gonna be wild yeah if you were
still in the house right now what would
you be doing depends from teamed up with
it depends like what I know like I knew
whether I jumped the gun on it or not I
knew there was a foursome with Ross
Marissa James and Mark now I was calling
it before I saw like them talk about it
so I don't know if it happened before I
was evicted officially or not but then
Ross and Ross also have a Final Four
with Brandi and are yes and I don't know
if they realize how strong they both are
so they're just gonna go wherever the
power is I mean you see them in the end
do you think Ross and Marissa I just
hope that if we do it's one and not both
of them okay because then at least
there's someone else said something else
there to make a case for you know yeah I
mean I think if I think if you see them
in the end then they they've both gotten
lucky and it's the chips have fallen the
way they hoped but it I mean it's gonna
start going so fast I can't imagine that
it's just gonna end up being a perfect
game for them sure um but we want to
move on to a little exclusive that we
have it's from the live feeds and it has
to do with this squash and brandy that
you actually told Bryce yeah yeah if you
go up and look right now Shannon's Fast
Five with us is up on et online right
now
you said the weirdest thing you saw in
the house was Brandis relationship with
this squash yeah and well something
weird happened with the squash beyond
what was already happening with the
squash watch this yeah I don't know what
to say Brandi no don't look at that
I knew I always knew I ever since he was
looking at your hat in the pantry I do
your mother excluding anyone I need the
whole time I'm really sorry
tell her you're sorry he says he's
really sorry
alright now why you still haven't was
more graphic than that what did you see
happen well it was one of those nights
where brandy had wine and she she
grabbed it and basically straddled it I
mean an awkward right here was I mean
her group stopped her because the the
live feeds were going and then when she
wasn't paying attention I it was before
there was a face on the squash I took it
and put it back in the pantry and I mean
I just have so many things to say but
there's so much time in that house yeah
see we start making up really stupid
games because there's nothing to do
right the boy needs real boredoms real
it's like do we play hide-and-go-seek I
mean we there's only so many places to
hide so you
I mean there was the telenovela right
you know we were learning Spanish
there's a twister game they did the
twister yeah I think you're really like
sitting around staring each other going
okay know what now what do we do
but you're also getting to learn about
each other a lot in this house we have
another live feed highlight here from
mark reliving his glory days but they
were both number one so that was flying
fly was 97 every morning was 1997 yeah
797 dude came out came out he was fine
it was everywhere
it was the most cosmos spins per week on
Radio 3000 no no more than that I think
fly one time had like almost 12,000
spins a week way up oh I think we set a
record four spins in a week about
everything yeah what was the most
interesting thing that you learned about
someone else in that house like a fun
fact a fun fact I'm trying to think um I
mean you learn a little bit about
everyone
and I mean honestly the gamers were
trying to retain everything because you
it could be a question yeah so we're
listening but we're also really trying
to retain like facts of where people
live and how many kids and one of the
names of the kids and the dogs and like
all of that stuff I mean I I think you
have to to say um Rosa had the most
interesting stories definitely and we
would try to pick her brain and
sometimes she'd remember there was like
live feed so she wouldn't say much and
then sometimes she would let something
slip that's gonna say do you feel like
that was sort of a tactic in the house
sort of leaving those bread crumbs
crumbs of information of what was
happening in the white house or do you
think she's being genuine about that I
mean we would ask her the questions you
usually wouldn't just say something
unsolicited but she was worried about
what she's allowed to say and she's
writing a book and she hasn't done an
official like big interview about it
also I think she was trying to hold on
to a lot of things but I feel like
that's more strategy outside of the
house than inside the house the way she
was yeah perhaps perhaps I mean I
remember James had asked her about the
tax code in the new tax code and the
only thing she said he said well then
why because I think she was saying there
were bad things about it and good things
or whatever and he goes well then why
did he change it to what it is now and
she was like to help his rich friends
she walked off yeah it was just enough
and she's out it's like okay where do
you in um Rosa stand today will you be
friends outside of the house I think
will be friendly I mean I I don't know
because I thought we'd be fine and we'd
be friends but like I'm watching the
live feeds and she's she's saying things
about me now too
maybe she can justify it and say well I
needed to bond with them and keeping
their good graces and it's tough but I
mean I I don't hold any ill well against
her it you know I think what for the
most part what she and I are R if it was
a game but she did say a few things that
were
outside of the game that were that were
hurtful and hard because they weren't
true and you know things I was worried
about that just shouldn't have been said
but I don't I don't feel like I'm gonna
have a problem with her and you know
like I could be friends with her
friendly Omarosa and Marissa are in the
final two who gets your vote on Marissa
she's playing the game we do have to
start wrapping things up here we do want
to watch Medes Fast Five really quick
because he was very fast with it who
will win if you had to call it now who's
gonna win Ross who was the worst
houseguest we love each other the worst
houseguest I would say is between James
and Brandi those two got the most kind
of annoying comments okay who is your
friend for life out of this game
everyone everybody absolutely what is
the strangest thing you saw in that
house the strangest thing in the house
me and Chuck Liddell had nail polish on
the toughest guys in the house or
whatever had nail polish on we watch
that go down and then a one word to
describe your Celebrity Big Brother
experience an emotional roller coaster
an emotional roller coaster for sure two
words two words they're from Metta and
if you want to watch Shannon answer
those same questions for us and it's up
on et online.com right now we do want to
ask you because you were very vocal in
your exit speech and even with Julie
about your work with the animals in
South Africa where are you gonna donate
the winnings to that cause so the way I
was gonna do it was this I'm not I
wasn't donating the winnings but what
what the winnings would allow me to do
is I never use donor money to pay for
administration costs for the charity it
always goes into the field so winnings
and anything that I make I was going to
use it as my my costs my administration
to cover me so if I need to travel
somewhere to do the work it covers my
fees and that way I'm never taking from
donor fees yeah
so that's that's kind of like my number
one rule and it's it's hard and that's
why I keep everything on a smaller scale
but I just believe if you're donating
money for the animals it should go to
the animals and how can people have they
want to get involved how can they they
can go to animal Avengers comm and rhino
review org is a new initiative that
we're just starting up and taking
signups and stuff for and then animal
Avengers on all social media platforms
have you already seen more support
coming in yeah for that yeah brother
yeah people have been amazing thank you
to everyone who has donated and written
to me and helped I'm still catching up
on everything but I'm so grateful and it
you know I I may not have won Big
Brother but the animals won and that's
all that matters to me so I love that
yeah well leave it on that positive note
make sure to subscribe to et on YouTube
follow us on Facebook do all those
things my Shannon yes and her charity on
all socials you're up to date and all
that stuff yes and then we will be with
Shannon on Sunday night at the Big
Brother finale so look out for that and
we will see you guys next time bye guys
bye
[Music]
you
you